[Musik]
rausgehen mit freunden treffen irgendwie
draußen in der stadt unterwegs zu sein
findet jetzt gar nicht mehr statt oder
habe ich mich zumindest noch nicht
wieder getraut ich bin da so ein
bisschen zwiegespalten ich finds auf
einer seite gut dass wir corona
weiterhin hart bekämpfen müssen auf der
anderen seite
dadurch dass sensibel intensiv
wettbewegungen zurzeit nicht mehr ganz
so krass auf dem vormarsch das würde ich
es eigentlich gar nicht schlecht wenn
wir ein bisschen lockern würden ich war
auch vor zwei wochen in quarantäne und
durfte auch kein pc etwas machen wenn so
ist das nicht genug da ist also nicht
genug kapazität und es nicht anders zu
machen es ist nur schade dass man jetzt
wieder so eine
wie schon so oft eine knappheit bei
solchen sachen
liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
herzlich willkommen zu diesem zdf
spezial indem wir uns zeit nehmen wollen
zeit um auch zwei jahre corona in
deutschland zurück zu blicken wir wollen
aber auch nach vorne schauen mit der
hoffnungsvollen frage ob es tatsächlich
bald vorbei sein könnte mit dieser
pandemie und natürlich soll es um die
aktuelle situation gehen in der die
infektionszahlen durch die decke
schießen die impfquote stagniert und
trotzdem hoffnung auf kommt hoffnung auf
ein normales leben schwierige
gemengelage die wir sortieren wollen die
von der politik organisiert werden muss
heute haben sich bund und länder wieder
mal zusammengeschaltet um über die krone
lage zu beratschlagen das motto kurs
halten so der kanzler die beschlüsse
die pcr tests sollen priorisiert werden
es soll nur noch pcr tests für
vulnerable gruppen für beschäftigte in
krankenhäusern praxen und der pflege
geben für alle anderen soll ein
zertifizierter antigen schnelltest
reichen auch die kontakt nachverfolgung
soll priorisiert werden im wesentlichen
nur noch im klinik- und pflegebereich
stattfinden ansonsten sollen infizierte
eigenverantwortlich ihre kontaktpersonen
informieren
und über viele weitere themen wie
großveranstaltungen wirtschaftshilfen
wird weiter beratschlagt lockerungs
strategien sollen erarbeitet werden wenn
die incidents es zulässt welche
strategie steckt jetzt hinter dem
politischen handeln das frage ich gleich
manuela schwesig die ministerpräsidenten
von mecklenburg vorpommern gleich weil
wir vorher auf diejenigen blicken wollen
die zur zeit am stärksten von den
infektionen betroffen sind zumindest
zahlenmäßig kinder und familien jeden
tag der bange blick aufs smartphone hat
sich die schule gemeldet was sagt die
kita leitung muss das geld abgeholt
werden droht die quarantäne schon wieder
für eltern sind die letzten wochen schon
mehr als nervig gewesen dazu kommt die
wachsende sorge um die oft ungeschützten
kinder kangas über familien am limit
drei kinder sozusagen also in
verschiedenen klassen an verschiedenen
schulen und ich finde moment wirklich
dramatisch war eigentlich jeden tag ein
neues kind
immer die nase
ist nicht doof es fehlt immer noch an
sicheren ideen und konzepten und einfach
die kinder zu durchsuchen das ist
fahrlässig dagegen demonstrieren diese
berliner familien am samstag vor der
kultusministerkonferenz mit masken und
abstand die forderungen angesichts
steigender infektionen an den schulen
kostenlose sfb zwei masken pcr tests und
luftfilter in ein klassen wollen wenn
man schon sagt wir wollen die präsenz
das ist sozusagen das maß aller dinge da
muss ich auch alles dafür tun die
familien fordern auch dass nicht mehr
alle zur schule müssen es solle hybrid
angebote geben mit online unterricht für
alle die zu hause gut lernen können und
kleinen präsenz gruppen für familien
ohne solche möglichkeit in den meisten
bundesländern hält die politik bisher an
der präsenzpflicht fest um soziale
härten zu vermeiden
gut lernen wie sie sich vor ort gerade
aber nicht mehr meint schulsprecher an
juden
meiner schule sind mittlerweile mehrere
klassen zu hause einfach weil so viele
positive fälle vorliegen und es werden
immer mehr sind auch einige lehrkräfte
mittlerweile zu hause und dann war auch
schon unterricht aus da ist viel lernen
sehr schwer
bundesweit lag die inzidenz unter
schulkindern zwischen fünf und 14 jahren
zuletzt doppelt so hoch wie in der
gesamtbevölkerung in berlin beträgt sie
weit über 3.000 und dennoch waren
zuletzt nur vier prozent der schulen im
wechsel unterricht
die behörden begründen ihr bisheriges
grünes licht für präsenzunterricht etwa
so mitunter bleiben schulen auf grün
weil viele schüler und lehrkräfte in
quarantäne sind und sie betonen viele
eltern und sehr viele schulleitungen
wollen zudem an der präsenzpflicht
festhalten doch viele eltern wünschen
sich diese sicher und nicht irgendwie
erscheint mir das dass die priorität
nicht darauf gelegt wird den familien
das einfacher zu machen die priorität
ist ganz klar irgendwie dafür zu sorgen
dass die beschäftigten weiter zur arbeit
gehen können also priorität auf ökonomie
und nicht auf gesundheitsschutz das
meint familienvater eric den wir
ebenfalls in berlin treffen den stress
der daran hängt hat seine familie gerade
erst durch die sitznachbarin seines
sohnes war positiv also hieß es selbst
pcr-test organisieren und dann hoffen
zum glück hat der erstklässler sich und
die familie nicht angesteckt schließlich
ist die mutter risikopatientin
anspannung bleibt aber
das ist quasi view russisch roulette
spielen ja so was gibt wird krank und
vielleicht haben wir glück und
vielleicht auch nicht
man fühlt sich wirklich komplett allein
gelassen mit den sorgen ganz grundlos
sind die nicht das risiko für schwere
omikron verläufe bei schulkindern halten
fachleute zwar weiter für gering zum
spätfolgen wie longo witt und pins einem
entzündungs syndrom ist die datenlage
jedoch noch unklar
heute nachmittag haben die berliner
behörden auf die anhaltende kritik
reagiert und darauf dass die
gesundheitsämter mit den fällen nicht
mehr hinterherkommen die präsenzpflicht
wird vorerst ausgesetzt familien können
ihre kinder nun zu hause lassen und
hoffen dass ihre schule adäquate
angebote dafür schafft
wenn die ausbleiben und der
präsenzunterricht nicht sicherer wird
wollen schulsprecher wie anjo geno
notfalls zu schuld streiks aufrufen
wir wollen nicht streiken aber wenn
weiterhin die politik nicht unsere
forderung eingeht dann sehen wir uns
gezwungen dass wir uns in sicherheit
begeben und die schulen sind aktuell
nicht der sichere platzierung
dazu vernetzen sie sich gerade
bundesweit und wollen ihre forderungen
bald rang hohen politiker in übergeben
in turin begrüße ich jetzt die
ministerpräsidentin von mecklenburg
vorpommern guten abend manuela schwesig
guten abend und mit konflikt durch die
schulen und kindergärten viele familien
im land machen sich wirklich große
sorgen und fühlen sich vergessen wieder
mal was sagen sie denn
erstens kann ich all diese sorgen
verstehen ich habe selber eine
fünfjährige tochter im kindergarten und
ein fast 15 jährigen sohn in der schule
und erlebe das natürlich dass man jeden
tag drauf schaut wie ist das
infektionsgeschehen in kita schule hier
sind die lagen in den ländern auch noch
sehr unterschiedlich und ganz wichtig
ist dass man doch als familie das
impfangebot nutzt ich bin jetzt sehr
froh dass wir uns dann entschieden haben
dass die kinder vollständig geimpft
werden das sollte man unbedingt nutzen
und gleichzeitig braucht es in den
ländern im stufen pläne dass man bei
höherem infektionsgeschehen eben zu
neuen maßnahmen greift sie zum beispiel
aussetzung präsenzunterricht das muss
aber nachdem infektionsgeschehen vor ort
angepasst sein in mecklenburg vorpommern
sind wir zum beispiel weniger betroffen
als in berlin ganz homann die eltern
aber auch in letzter zeit dass sie pcr
tests machen konnten die umsonst waren
wenn die ware brot war und es gab viele
weitere gründe jetzt eine priorisierung
kommen sprich werden kinder und
jugendliche und lehrkräfte
ausgeschlossen und wer wird priorisiert
wir müssen auch einmal über diese
priorisierung sprechen sie ist definitiv
notwendig weil wir nicht genügend pcr
kapazitäten haben für diese starke
mikrowelle und deswegen muss man eine
priorisierung machen aber deswegen
sollten wir auch noch mal hinschauen
dass da eben auch diese ganze frage
setting kita und schule neben den
krankenhäusern und pflegeeinrichtungen
nicht vergessen wird und
gleichzeitig ist es eben wichtig dass
wir in den ländern diese stufen pläne
haben mit gesundheitsexperten abgestimmt
wie wir vorgehen in diesem bereich
wichtig ist aber ich kann es noch mal
wiederholen auch hier der impfschutz für
die kinder wo schon möglich ist da ist
also das letzte wort nicht gesprochen
hört man raus wenn man sich die
ergebnisse von heute anschaut was ist
denn die gesamtstrategie das ist vielen
nicht wirklich klar geworden ein
kontrolliertes durchlaufen von omikron
zu lassen oder infektionen doch
irgendwie verhindern
wir lassen einen durchlaufen nicht zu
wir haben ja viele maßnahmen strengere
maßnahmen als andere europäische staaten
wir halten an den kontakt beschränkungen
fest wir machen weiter zweig plos zum
beispiel in der gastronomie aber auch im
einzelhandel zweig wir haben außerdem
weitere schutzmaßnahmen wie schließung
zum beispiel von diskotheken auch
großveranstaltungen sind nur ganz
begrenzt und manchen ländern noch gar
nicht möglich also dass sind ja viele
einschränkende maßnahmen und
gleichzeitig ist aber auch klar wir
müssen uns mit impfen und boostern
schützen dass es die doppelstrategie von
deutschland und wir sehen dass diese
maßnahmen wirken sie werden aber die
omikron welle nicht ganz aufhalten
eine frage zu impfpflicht noch für
umgekommen würde die impfpflicht ja zu
spät kommen was aber im herbst für eine
situation vorherrscht ist ja wirklich
ungewiss kann man auch so einer
unsicheren grundlage eine so
weitreichende entscheidung treffen
ja kann man und muss man warum
wir können so nicht mehr weitermachen
das geht nicht dass wir jedes mal in den
herbst und winter laufen und wie viele
menschen über 70 prozent die sich impfen
lassen haben die alles dafür tun dass
wir aus dieser pandemie kommen kommen
aber nicht raus weil andere es nicht tun
und deswegen steht die politik voran der
deutsche bundestag vor dieser
schwierigen herausforderung welche
freiheitsrechte schränke ich jetzt ein
aber ich sage es mal ganz deutlich mir
fällt nichts mehr ein wenn mir eine
gastronomen sagt wir haben alles gemacht
wir sind komplett geimpft komplett
gebucht hat die mitarbeiter wir halten
uns an alles wir können nicht immer
diese einschränkung für die kinder für
die wirtschaft machen da müssen wir
zusammen ein weg aus dieser pandemie
finden sagt manuela schwesig
ministerpräsidenten von mecklenburg
vorpommern danke für das gespräch
ich danke ihnen und bleiben sie gesund
priorisiert wird immer dann wenn nicht
genug da ist und pcr tests werden bei
steigenden infektionszahlen knapp werden
das steht fest was tun die kapazitäten
erhöhen dafür ist es aber etwas spät
priorisieren das soll kommen oder
schnelltests in die labore schicken auch
das wird jetzt überlegt aber fein
im labor berlin herrscht hochbetrieb
und nicht nur hier
wir haben in der vergangenen woche rund
zwei millionen pcr tests durchgeführt
das ist das maximum seit beginn der
pandemie von wenn man sich jetzt die
infektionszahlen nochmal anschaut aus
den letzten tagen weiß ich dass wir für
diese woche dann noch mal höhere zahlen
erwartet
laut robert koch institut steht in
deutschland eine gesamtkapazität von 2,4
millionen pcr tests pro woche zur
verfügung doch diese grenze ist fast
ausgereizt
wir schaffen das was sie im moment am pc
anforderungen haben gerade noch so mehr
pcs werden wir nicht leisten können es
scheitert im moment nicht an geräten es
scheitert nicht an den test materialien
sondern wir brauchen für die pcr test
und hochqualifiziertes personal was
ausgebildet sein muss für die berufe und
davon gibt's ja wenig deshalb der ruf
nach priorisierungen
bevorzugt und weiterhin verpflichtend
pcr getestet werden soll vor allem
personal kritischer infrastrukturen wie
krankenhäuser und altenheime für alle
anderen soll ein schnelltest aus einem
testcenter zum freitag nach der
quarantäne reichen doch jeder fünfte der
auf dem markt befindlichen schnelltest
ist unzuverlässig wie studien zeigen
experten wie der virologe professor bodo
cluster verweisen auf weitere schwächen
anti gen tests sind natürlich immer
weniger empfindlich als pcr-test das
liegt in der natur der sache dass es
methodisch bedingt das heißt antigen
test sie werden immer weniger menschen
delektieren können als peter testet
trotz solcher bedenken haben bund und
länder die test und quarantänemaßnahmen
bereits gelockert fortan gelten diese
regeln für infizierte und
kontaktpersonen beträgt die
quarantänezeit nur noch zehn tage sie
können die isolation bereits nach sieben
tagen beenden wenn sie mindestens 48
stunden lang beschwerdefrei sind und ein
negatives testergebnis einer textstelle
vorliegen für medizinisches fachpersonal
bleibt der pcr test pflicht wer seine
zweite impfung innerhalb der letzten
drei monate bekommen hat oder gemustert
ist muss nicht mehr in quarantäne
auch für genesene hat sich etwas
geändert ihr status geld mittlerweile
nur noch drei statt sechs monate wer
eine corona infektion innerhalb der
letzten drei monate überstanden hat muss
sich fortan nicht mehr isolieren
eine lockerung trotz hoher
infektionszahlen in der arena klinik für
altersmedizin in berlin hat man bedenken
doch man benötige dringend das personal
das ist definitiv ein spagat auf der
einen seite die sicherheit für unsere
patienten wird das pflegepersonal als
auch eben die die medizinische
versorgung der patienten vollstens zu
erfüllen pcr test sind knapp
schnelltests eher unzuverlässig der
berufsverband der akkreditierten
medizinischen labor will deshalb jetzt
vermehrt auf eine dritte variante setzen
labor basierte anti gen tests die
qualität der labor basierten anti
ginters so zwischen den antigen
schnelltest und der pcr anzusehen wir
machen den test hier bei uns im labor in
einer qualitätsgesicherten umgebung aber
in anderen teams was für uns natürlich
eine entlastung ist solange es
ausreichend pcr tests gab war die
nachfrage nach labor basierten antigen
tests gering das könnte sich jetzt
ändern
vom prozedere ist es so dass sie dann
auch wiederum zu einer abstrich stelle
gehen würden oder zu ihrem hausarzt
dortmund abstrich genommen bekommen die
probe geht zu unserem labor und wir
müssen das 100% sicherheit geben auch
diese labor basierten schnelltests nicht
ein risiko bleibt
lockerungen bei test- und quarantäne
pflichten einerseits andererseits
explodieren die infektionszahlen es ist
eine wette darauf dass omikron
erkrankungen wirklich deutlich harmloser
verlaufen als die mit der data variante
dr christoph spricht medizinjournalist
und arzt ist jetzt bei uns schön gerahmt
schönen abend eher nervös wenn jetzt die
mikrowelle so schnell durch deutschland
fegt welche bedeutung hat das testen
generell wichtiger denn je oder lässt
sich die verbreitung so auch nicht mehr
wirklich bremsen er ist mir natürlich
schon schön wenn man genügend tests
hätte gerade pcr-test antigen test alles
was da ist aber das problem ist die hat
man natürlich nicht einfach in jeglicher
menge zur verfügung erst recht nicht bei
diesen infektionszahlen insofern ist
jetzt die variante auf die anti gen
tests zu gehen einfach eine pragmatische
lösung pcr ist natürlich sehr viel
genauer aber muss auch wissen was man
will will man sozusagen das letzte virus
fitzelchen sehen dann braucht man die
pcr test oder will man sehen ob jemand
infektiös ist dann können die anti gen
test noch eine gute orientierung geben
wenn ich jetzt auch schnell das
angewiesen bin welche sind zuverlässig
welche weniger gibt es irgendwas auf was
ich achten muss also als er die
kernfrage schlechthin und da muss man
sagen dass wirklich ein großes problem
es gibt zwar eine liste von paul ehrlich
institut das ist das zuständige institut
ihren deutschland da kann auch jeder hin
aber ganz ehrlich für den laien ist
diese liste quasi nicht lesbar die ist
auch nie verleihen gedacht sondern da
muss man schon ein bisschen ahnung von
haben es gibt jetzt eine gruppe von
programmierern in berlin unter schnell
test de haben die sich mal die mühe
gemacht diese ganzen tabellen ein
bisschen sozusagen zuschauer
freundlicher und und und
menschenfreundlicher zu machen dass man
sie besser lesen kann dort kann man dann
den eigenen test eingeben sogar scannen
und dann schauen wie schneidet er denn
so ungefähr ab aber hier muss
tatsächlich noch nachgelegt werden so
dass auch der laie eben sehen kann den
test den ich mir das vielleicht gerade
gekauft habe taugt er was oder taugt er
nichts also noch nicht wirklich
freundlich für verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher wenn sich jetzt alle
anstecken glauben viele die impfungen
sei nicht mehr so nötig trugschluss oder
ist auch was dran an so einem argument
nein daran ist wirklich gar nichts dran
das ist wirklich ein massiver
trugschluss und wir haben es ja schon so
oft gesagt es ist eben ein unterschied
ob ich dieses virus auch dieses
scheinbar mildere omikron virus geimpft
trifft oder eben als ungeimpfte und nach
wie vor ist es so als ungeimpfter vor
allen dingen wenn ich älter bin vor
allen dingen wenn ich vor erkrankungen
habe gehe ich ein großes risiko ein das
würde ich nicht gerne tun dass ich mich
auch als geimpfte und gebuchter mit
bewusster mit omikron eines tages an
stecken werde das ist fast sicher aber
da habe ich dann wirklich alles getan um
eben einen solchen schweren verlauf zu
verhindern kurz gesagt kann man sagen
die impfung ist nicht so sehr der
solidarische aktion ein ganz egoistisch
eine ein schutz für mich selber
vielen dank für das gespräch doktor
christoph specht
beim bund länder treffen heute ebenfalls
thema die impfpflicht die allgemeine und
die einrichtungs bezogene diese ist
bereits beschlossen für bestimmte
gruppen zb für alle die im krankenhaus
oder pflegeheim arbeiten sie gilt ab dem
15 märz manchen kliniken ging das aber
nicht schnell genug und so spüren die
ersten impf verweigerer in der pflege
schon jetzt die konsequenzen sie dürfen
nicht mehr arbeiten und das obwohl das
gesetz noch gar nicht in kraft getreten
ist birgit frank mathias mieg mit einem
beispiel aus münchen
werbung mit dem eigenen personal
doch seit jahresanfang ist nicht mehr
jeder mitarbeiter willkommen der streit
in der arte mit klinik in münchen dreht
sich um das beschäftigungsverbot für
ungeimpfte personal zum schutz der
patienten so hat es die klinikleitung
festgelegt werden ungeimpfte mitarbeiter
im dienstplan nicht mehr berücksichtigt
das betrifft 80 ungeimpfte von 7.500
mitarbeitern des trägers bundesweit nur
wenige ziehen konsequenzen
kündigung gibt es ganz wenige seinen
drei oder vier
klagen gibt es auch relativ weniger 4
ist der heutige stand wir sind also
ausnahmeerscheinung und eigentlich haben
wir einen innerlich guten dialog mit
unseren mitarbeitern gegensätzliche
positionen aber wir versuchen
unverändert sie zum impfen zu bewegen
intensivstation pro kubik patient eine
pflegekraft rund um die uhr die
pflegerin für intensivpflege sonja lin
huber ist vollständig geimpft
wir hatten sehr frühe klinik interne
impfkampagne und hatten eigentlich auch
schon bis ende letzten jahres fast alle
mitarbeiter impfen können aber natürlich
gab es auch den einen oder anderen der
bis zum schluss die impfungen verweigert
hat die 2g regel für beschäftigte gilt
in den atem at kliniken im alleingang
seit jahresanfang also deutlich bevor
die gesetzliche regelung dazu mitte märz
in kraft treten wird warum eigentlich
also wir haben überhaupt nicht über
rechtliche grundlagen nachgedacht
sondern eher den fall gesehen dass ein
patient gegen eine hüftprothese zum
beispiel ins krankenhaus kommt sich
durch ein mitarbeiter von uns infiziert
und anschließend verstirbt das hätte
übels gespräche mit seinen
familienangehörigen nach sich gezogen
das wäre eine niederlage für uns alle
gewesen und das wollten wir vermeiden
die öffentliche reaktion in den sozialen
netzwerken hingegen ist gespalten viele
verurteilen die 2g entscheidung so was
gehört verboten in dieser zeit schutz
der patienten dass ich nicht lache
hoffentlich kündigen alle die darauf
keinen bock haben
da wird der klinikchef bald selbst essen
servieren und hintern putzen
die klinik hat niemandem gekündigt aber
für ungeimpfte gilt ohne arbeit kein
lohn dieses quasi berufsverbot ist
umstritten die gewerkschaft verdi hält
es für rechts bedenklich
wir glauben dass viele kollegen
kolleginnen sofern sie auf uns zukommen
rechtsschutz beantragen tatsächlich
erfolgsaussichten haben den arbeitgeber
auf annahme verzug zu verklagen weil die
kollegen sind ja bereit ihre
arbeitsleistung zu erbringen
der arbeitgeber nimmt dieser nicht an
allerdings wie gesagt es ist eine
einzelfallbetrachtung
das wohl der patientinnen und patienten
die atmet kliniken jedenfalls stellen es
über das arbeitsrecht
abrechnungs oder nicht das werden die
gerichte entscheiden und für die zukunft
gilt die gesundheitsämter werden jeden
einzelfall prüfen ob ausnahmen
übergangsfristen oder tätigkeitsverbote
nötig sind
diese woche noch will der bundestag über
die allgemeine impfpflicht debattieren
erste konkrete vorschläge liegen bereits
vor die diskussion ist also eröffnet
eine schwierige entscheidung wird das
für alle abgeordneten die ganz sicher
auch in die länder schauen werden die
eine impfpflicht schon beschlossen haben
österreich italien und griechenland
jeweils unterschiedlich ist sie dort
geregelt wie genau zeigen unsere
korrespondentinnen und korrespondenten
vor ort
sie sind das die italiens regierung in
sachen corona bekämpfung besonders im
auge hat bei älter ist als 50 jahre
unterliegt seit rund zwei wochen der
impfpflicht und wer sich der mit der sec
zahlt ab erst im februar eine strafe von
einmalig 100 euro
die verschiedenen datenbanken des
gesundheitssystems werden abgeglichen
die mit den bereits geimpften und die
mit den gebuchten impfterminen werden
keiner zu finden ist erhält eine
verwaltungsstrafe grund der maßnahme
menschen über 50 seien durch das corona
virus besonders gefährdet landeten
weitaus häufiger im krankenhaus
zugleich aber waren zwei millionen
bürger dieser altersgruppe bisher
ungeimpft die impfpflicht für sie finden
viele in italien richtig
und das ergebnis kann man doch sehen
denn als es weniger geimpfte gab gab es
auch mehr todesfälle und mehr
krankenhausaufenthalte
und katastrophales brauchen wir eine
impfpflicht
nicht nur für die über 50-jährigen
sondern für alle arbeitnehmer gilt zudem
ab mitte februar nur noch mit dem
sogenannten super green pass also zweig
kann man an den arbeitsplatz wer die
nicht hat also nicht geimpft oder
genesen ist kann ich arbeiten erhält
auch keinen lohn
seit jahresbeginn hat die omikron
variante auch in italien die zahl der
neuinfektionen nach oben schnellen
lassen und in den krankenhäusern liegen
überwiegend ungeimpfter
ministerpräsident rudd wollte daher eine
allgemeine impfpflicht für alle
erwachsenen und scheiterte damit an
teilen seiner koalition doch auch die
jetzige regelung macht druck die zahl
der arzt empfohlen hat zuletzt
zugenommen
auch griechenland hat anfang des jahres
eine impfpflicht für ältere bürger
eingeführt für die über 60 jährigen wer
sich hier nicht impfen lässt zahlt 100
euro jeden monat aufs neue auf dem
fischmarkt den athen- herrschen dazu
geteilte meinungen
die strafe finde ich eigentlich nicht
richtig aber wie will man die leute
sonst dazu bringen diese elende impfung
zu akzeptieren sind wir die dummen die
sich an ihm ich werde nicht zulassen
dass ich meine mutter impfen muss die
100 euro strafe übernehme ich sie
bekommt nur 400 euro rente will sich
aber nicht impfen lassen um die
krankenhäuser zu entlasten entschloss
sich die regierung von
ministerpräsidenten mitsotakis zu der
maßnahme geimpft sind zwar knapp drei
viertel der bürger griechenlands aber
bei den über 60-jährigen waren noch zu
viele ungeübte die bußgelder angekündigt
wurden ließen sich über 217.000 doch
impfen ein erfolg
wir möchten die maßnahme daher in dieser
sensiblen gruppe weiter fortsetzen um
die zahl der geimpften dort noch weiter
zu erhöhen die daten der betroffenen
werden von der staatlichen
sozialversicherung an das finanzamt
weitergeleitet dass die gelder eintreibt
sie sollen nun so will es der
ministerpräsident den staatlichen
krankenhäusern zugute kommen
in österreich hatten impfgegner und
corinna leutner hand in hand mit
rechtsextremen monatelang stimmung
gemacht gegen die impfpflicht doch nun
hat eine parteiübergreifende mehrheit
von volksvertretern auch von der
opposition die impfpflicht für
erwachsene beschlossen wir müssen uns
darauf vorbereiten dass wir nach der
mikrowelle über die nächsten monate
immunität verlieren werden in österreich
wenn nicht geimpft wird die impfpflicht
geht ab anfang februar ab 15 märz
kontrolliert die polizei den impfstatus
wiederholungs verweigern drohen strafen
bis zu 3600 euro laut umfragen ist das
land gespalten über die impfpflicht
rechtspopulisten versuchen das für sich
zu nutzen sagt politikwissenschaftler
peter filzmaier
die impfpflicht ist politisch brisant
weil die drittgrößte parlamentspartei
das ist die freiheitliche partei radikal
dagegen spricht nicht etwa pro und
contra und dass es zwischen schwarz und
weiß auch mittel wege und grauzonen
geben würde das führt zu einer
polarisierung die teilweise auch gewalt
bisher sind knapp drei viertel der
österreicher doppelt geimpft knapp die
hälfte ist gepustet
österreich ist das erste europäische
land das eine allgemeine corona im
pflicht eingeführt hat für die aktuelle
infektionswelle kommt das jedoch zu spät
denn wegen omikron steigt derzeit wieder
die zeit der korona patienten in den
krankenhäusern
die impfpflicht soll das
gesundheitssystem und das öffentliche
leben vor den auswirkungen der korona
pandemie schützen
vor fast genau zwei jahren tauchte
corona zum ersten mal in deutschland auf
zwei jahre ist das nun schon her und
ganz sicher haben sie zu hause die
unterschiedlichsten erinnerungen und
gefühle wenn sie so zurückdenken frust
hoffnung und auch stolz über das
geschaffte haben diese zeit geprägt aber
auch sehr viel leid fast 120.000
menschen sind in deutschland an oder im
zusammenhang mit corona gestorben viele
millionen menschen konnten aber
geschützt werden auch weil nach
unglaublich kurzer zeit ein impfstoff
zur verfügung stand eine situation die
vieles veränderte einige menschen aber
dann doch nicht überzeugte zwei jahre
corona ein rückblick von burkhard jupe
der erreger der neu entstandenen
atemwegserkrankungen aus china setzte in
einem ersten fall von china nach
deutschland geschafft die firma webasto
und der nähe von münchen hier beginnt es
im januar vor zwei jahren
deutschland ist absolut gut vorbereitet
wir haben ein hervorragendes
gesundheitssystem eine infizierte
chinesische mitarbeiterin bringt das
virus ins bayerische stockdorf der
gesundheitsminister meint wir nehmen die
dinge sehr ernst in deutschland gibt es
neue promotion
gemeldet werden diese aus heinsberg in
nordrhein westfalen unter 300 jecken
sorgt ein infiziertes ehepaar für
ansteckungen die furcht verbreitet sich
schneller als das virus
zu den alltagsgebrauch ist desinfektions
masken tragen oder handschuhe tragen
nicht notwendig hygiene und
abstandsregeln sollen das virus in
schach halten
sie können alle in einen meter abstand
sitzen abstand hilft nur bedingt
großveranstaltungen werden abgesagt
erste bundesländer veranlassen
schließungen ab kommenden montag werden
die schulen und kindertagesstätten
kindergärten
geschlossen das virus breitet sich
weiter aus deutschland geht in den look
down seit dem zweiten weltkrieg gab es
keine herausforderung an unser land mehr
bei der es so sehr auf unser gemeinsames
solidarisches handeln ankommt ganze
pflegeheime sind nun betroffen besonders
hier steigt die zahl der toten
erst nicht gewollt und plötzlich ist sie
da die masken pflicht
der sparkassen zur geltung
ein großteil der masken zunächst
handgemacht stoff mit guten ratschlägen
sie müssen regelmäßig gewaschen werden
beziehungsweise gebügelt in den backofen
gelegt oder in die mikrowelle ende april
die instanzen sinken die temperaturen
steigen deutschland möchte lokal
regional differenziert deshalb wird es
von der dänischen grenze und der ost-
und nordseeküste im norden bis hin zu
den alpen
unterschiedliche regeln auch geben
öffnungen nach und nach nicht bundesweit
geregelt nicht allen gefällt das ich
glaube es ist im interesse der menschen
der bürgerinnen und bürger dass es für
ganz deutschland eine strategie gibt mit
den vorsichtigen lockerungen wird über
den sommer der widerstand öffentlich
[Musik]
und damit
wir haben uns ist er auch er recht gut
umgehen der sommer geht der herbst kommt
und mit ihm ein lockdown leid
wenn wir das einen monat mit aller
konsequenz durchhalten kann das in
dieser zweiten welle ein wellenbrecher
sein nicht alles wird im herbst 2020
geschlossen die schulen bleiben auf nur
stellt sich hier die frage filtern oder
frieren
vielleicht macht man auch mal eine
kleine kniebeuge oder so oder klatscht
in die hände die ersten impfungen folgen
an den letzten tagen des jahres 2020
senioren zuerst
doch das impfen es kommt nicht so
schnell voran der lok downlight und auch
das wieder eingeführte homeschooling
alles zieht sich in die länge und soll
dadurch keine poster ruhe verstärkt
werden die prompt wieder kassiert wird
gleichwohl weiß ich natürlich dass
dieser gesamte vorgang zusätzliche
verunsicherung ausgelöst
das bedauere ich zutiefst und
dafür bitte ich alle bürgerinnen und
bürger um verzeihung die impfkampagne
sie nimmt fahrt auf doch nicht jeder
wird davon erreicht genug impfstoff ist
nun da
das was wir jetzt erreichen müssen ist
eine hohe impfquoten dann kann der
herbst auch sehr entspannt sein doch
delta kommt und die entspannung geht der
bundestagswahlkampf die
regierungsbildung keine zeit für harte
maßnahmen aus delta wird omicron aus
herbst wird gewinnt den alltag 2022
bestimmen verschiedenste gegen und die
diskussionen die impfpflicht
also ich persönlich habe immer gesagt
dass ich mich für eine allgemeine
impfpflicht aussprechen werde menschen
die das nicht wollen gegen ihren willen
dazu deswegen halte ich für nicht
verantwortbar was ich also richtig finde
ist dass ich mich als
bundesgesundheitsminister
nicht offiziell zu dieser frage äußert
auch das war von vornherein so geplant
dass es sich dabei um eine debatte im
deutschen bundestag handeln soll eine
impfpflicht ist kein vorhaben der
koalition
deutschland im jahr drei der pandemie es
bleiben immer fragen da ist man sich
bloß einig dass man sich unheilig ist
am mittwoch letztlich corona in
deutschland zum zweiten mal und genau
darum wird sich die tägliche service
sendung volle kanne diesem jahrestag
widmen mittwoch kurz nach neun uhr
morgens mit gesprächen analysen und
rückblicken und natürlich mit der alles
entscheidenden frage wie lange geht das
alles noch ist der ausweg oder kommt
doch alles ganz anders einen vagen
ausblick gibt es auch jetzt schon hier
bei uns von dortmundern
seit zwei jahren kämpft die welt gegen
korona
mittlerweile ist klar wir können das
virus nicht komplett weg kämpfen lars
koch 2 ist gekommen um zu bleiben
die hoffnung ist dass die pandemie in
eine ndm übergeht
aber was heißt das
anders als beim weltumspannenden
infektionsgeschehen der pandemie sind
die ausbrüche bei der ende mai lokal
oder auf bestimmte bevölkerungsgruppen
beschränkt so wie wir das zum beispiel
schon von der grippe kennen die vor
allem älterer und vor erkrankte menschen
hart treffen kann
spanien überraschte als erstes land in
der eu mit der aussage man wolle nach
dem abklingen der aktuellen welle in die
endemische phase übergehen über 80
prozent der spanierinnen sind
vollständig geimpft und die sind die
beschränkungen leid
wir müssen weiterhin vorsichtig sein
aber wir müssen lernen mit dem virus zu
leben sagt diese spanierin und
er meint wir leben doch schon mit dem
virus jetzt müssen wir wieder frei
erleben können
spanien will corona in zukunft wie eine
beherrschbare grippe behandeln keine
beschränkungen keine tests kann die nach
verfolgungen ärzte sind lediglich
angehalten das infektionsgeschehen im
auge zu behalten
auch großbritanniens gesundheitsminister
verkündet für das frühjahr den übergang
in die hände
wir werden das virus und seine
zukünftigen varianten nicht ausrotten
können instead stattdessen müssen wir
lernen damit zu leben genau wie wir
gelernt haben mit der krippe zu leben
und solch einer langfristigen plan im
frühjahr
wie die strategie genau aussieht soll im
märz verkündet werden mit cupid leben
die mit einer beherrschbaren grippe es
wird sich zeigen ob das wirklich ein
schritt zurück zur normalität ist
das wollen wir vertiefen mit der
professorin isabella eckerle virologin
der universitätskliniken in genf guten
abend
ist die hoffnung berechtigt was spricht
dafür aus ihrer sicht das mit omikron
die pandemie enden könnte und corona wie
eine grippe vielleicht behandelt wird
genauer also omikron wird sicher dafür
sorgen dass zeitnah sehr sehr viele von
uns oder die allermeisten wahrscheinlich
mit dem erreger in kontakt kommen werden
das heißt wir werden im monat dagegen
aufbauen und diese grund immunität in
der bevölkerung die wir der erste
schritt richtung ende nie sein die
spannende frage ist dann allerdings was
passiert im herbst also ich gehe davon
aus dass wir im sommer wahrscheinlich
wieder sinkende infektionszahlen haben
werden dass wir eine gute situation
haben aber der herbst ist noch lange hin
wir wissen nicht bleibt omikron wenn
omikron bleibt reicht dieser immunschutz
den wir haben oder kommt vielleicht auch
noch mal eine neue variante
und das sind noch fragen die die diesen
übergang zur zu ende wie im moment noch
etwas
unklar erscheinen lassen da würde ich
gerne noch mal nachfragen neue
mutationen kombinationen auch von delta
und omikron da wird viel darüber geredet
und schon gewarnt was ist dazu schon
bekannt und rechnen sie damit
genau also es hat vor einigen wochen die
meldung zirkuliert dass es eine
kombination zwischen delta und nikon gab
da hat sich dann am schluss heraus
gestellt dass eine kontamination im
labor war das war ein fehler bei der
auswertung also diese variante die gibt
es noch nicht man muss allerdings sagen
wir wissen eigentlich noch nicht so viel
wo diese varianten herkommen und wir
wissen eigentlich auch noch nicht wie
lange es dauert bis dieses virus
sozusagen eine balance mit unserem
immunsystem findet und alle seine tricks
sage ich jetzt mal
ausgeschöpft hat also da gibt es noch
viele offene fragen und das heißt für
uns wird in zukunft die überwachung per
sequenzierung ganz ganz wichtig bleiben
und es ist wir haben in der
vergangenheit gesehen dieses virus hat
ein hohes potenzial sich zu verändern
und ich rechne damit dass uns dieses
virus vielleicht auch in der zukunft
noch überraschen wird was es dann
bedeutet ob dieser variante eine
schwerere erkrankung macht oder die
immunität umgehen kann das kann man
jetzt noch nicht sagen also das muss man
dann eben untersuchen wenn es soweit ist
und das kann man zum beispiel auch gar
nicht aufgrund des sequenz sagen also da
muss man wirklich dann auch experimente
machen da wissen wir eigentlich noch
nicht genug drei war wenn wir jetzt auf
die nächsten wochen schauen mehrere
hunderttausend infizierte am tag in
deutschland damit müssen wir rechnen
heißt es die zahlen klingen ja wirklich
bedrohlich wie sehr sind sie das auch
na ja also wir müssen jetzt einfach mal
sehen dass diese schere zwischen den
infektionszahlen und der
krankenhauseinweisungen oder der der
akuten gesundheitlichen bedrohungen die
geht ja immer weiter auseinander und das
liegt einfach daran dass sehr viele
menschen jetzt geimpft sind dass wir
auch den booster haben und
erfreulicherweise ist es so dass diese
impfung sehr sehr gut auch gegen omikron
zumindest vor schwerer erkrankungen und
fotos schützt und das war immer der sinn
der impfung dass diese impfung die
infektion verhindert das war eigentlich
schon relativ früh klar dass das
wahrscheinlich nicht so gut klappen wird
oder nur für einen kurzen zeitraum
das heißt die wichtige frage ist jetzt
was was passiert in den gruppen zum
beispiel die eben noch nicht von diesem
impfschutz profitieren können und das
sind zum beispiel die kinder unter fünf
das sind hoch betagte das sind
immunsupprimierten und das ist einfach
glaube ich jetzt eine situation die das
ganze infektionsgeschehen sehr sehr viel
komplexer machen wir haben menschen die
haben eine gute grund im monat durch die
dreifache impfung und für die ist diese
infektion jetzt wirklich kein großes
problem mehr und wir haben aber eben
noch gruppen in der bevölkerung die
durchaus auch noch ein risiko für eine
schwere erkrankung haben und wie man
jetzt daraus balanciert und wann man
dann die maßnahmen aufhebt und sagt
jetzt akzeptiert man ein höheres maß an
zirkulation das ist eine schwierige
frage
sie haben schon angedeutet ein großteil
ist geimpft oder gelesen hunderttausende
werden sich auch in den nächsten tagen
anstecken
den virus muss ja zwangsläufig dann
irgendwann die power ausgeben rechnen
sie damit dass die kurve schon bald dann
wirklich auch steil nach unten sinkt in
anderen ländern hat sich das angedeutet
aber noch nicht ganz so bewahrheitet wie
sie ihre vorhersage
ja also man hat jetzt in ersten
laborexperimenten gesehen wenn man mit
omikron infiziert war dann hat man wie
zu erwarten auch gegen omikron erstmal
eine immunität das heißt dass man jetzt
sofort wieder mit dem gleichen erreger
infiziert wird ist unwahrscheinlich und
dadurch ist es tatsächlich so wenn wir
so ein us infektionsgeschehen haben dass
dem erreger sozusagen die wirte ausgehen
und da muss man auch gar keine 100
prozent erreichen sondern man weiß eben
dass menschen sich vor allem in
bestimmten netzwerken
bewegen und wenn dieses netzwerk
sozusagen gesättigt ist weil sehr viele
es schon hatten dann ist zu erwarten
dass die infektionskette die wird aber
nicht auf null runter gehen das heißt er
wird es durchaus auch noch eine gewisse
aktivitäten
die infektion geben aber die wird nicht
mehr also dieses massive
infektionsgeschehen wie wir das im
moment haben das wird sicher nicht über
wochen am aufrechtzuerhalten sein
professor elisabeth leckere vielen dank
für ihre einschätzungen
wir müssen uns wohl mit dem gedanken
abfinden dass es auch diesmal kein ganz
schnelles ende geben wird was es genau
heißt mit corona leben lernen das wird
uns sicher noch längere zeit
beschäftigen
das war unser zdf spezial für heute hier
im zdf geht es jetzt weiter mit einem
ganz besonderen film die
wannseekonferenz eine besprechung mit
anschließendem frühstück heißt es im
protokoll in wahrheit planen 15 nazis
kühl und abgrundtief unmenschlich die
industrielle ermordung der juden
erschütternd gut erzählt erschütternd
gut gespielt die wannseekonferenz jetzt
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]